this is a photo i think you sent it to
matt uh just the other day just to go
hey remember these dudes
here's 17 year old uh matt and ben in a
photo booth look at this
now listen
hard not to see that those guys are
going to make it yeah those guys clearly
have stories
lots of people may think ben affleck and
matt damon's friendship started with
goodwill hunting
[Applause]
oh what's up you still talk come
but the a-listers were pals way before
they co-wrote and starred in the
oscar-winning 1997 flick and now they're
having a good laugh at some teenage
throwback picks
is ben really your best friend yeah i
mean we grew up together i mean you know
best friend is kind of a children's
concept really i mean ultimately but but
yeah i mean like you know we
i've known him for 35 years we both were
in love with this you know
the same thing with with acting and and
with filmmaking and yeah
and
i don't know i think we kind of fed on
each other's obsession and
doing some really formative important
years and and and that that bonded us
for life i think on wednesday the
longtime friend stopped by the tonight
show starring jimmy fallon and shared
two snaps from when they were 17 posing
it up in a photo booth hard enough to
see that those guys are going to make it
yeah those guys clearly have stars
i think it's the matching puka necklaces
so that's buddies that's bff's right
there come on
that's bff for life the two also shared
a photo from the premiere of goodwill
hunting in 1997.
you wouldn't imagine that those two
idiots would still be around
not sure what was going through my head
there yeah looks a little like a
zoolander
if i can create a basic disguise for us
with this professional makeup kit
we may just be able to sneak in
undetected of course e.t was with matt
and ben back when they were promoting
the now classic drama here's what ben
had to say at the time about writing
goodwill hunting matt and i decided to
uh to write something that we would do
initially you know for very
inexpensively do this kind of low budget
thing and then it sort of got
it sort of blew up from there which was
really exciting but uh
it was you know it's one of those hot
weird hollywood like fantasy stories you
know it's kind of like winning the
lottery
fast forward more than two decades bet
and matt are back together for the last
duel the first film they've co-written
and co-starred in since goodwill hunting
the most unspeakable charge has been
brought against you the actors attended
the new york premiere of the highly
anticipated flick and opened up to e.t
about their long-lasting friendship over
those 25 years you know matt and i have
just been friends and worked together in
the capacity of like you know we show
each other movies and talking so it
doesn't feel like oh i haven't seen this
guy for 25 years i remember you but it
is it is nice it's cool to be
uh
have written another movie with him and
and uh we we loved it and we definitely
want to do more of it you know we're
like this is fun why aren't we doing
this why haven't we done this for 25
years yeah if you told me 25 years ago
i'd be like we made it we're still
we're still working okay good
[Music]
you